Did you know there is a country in South
America where most of its population are of
Indian origin and where the official language
is English?
If you don´t know which country I´m talking
about, don’t worry, because this is one
of the least known countries in the region
and, to be fair, the media doesn’t really
pay much attention to it.
So, a small, little-known country, the media
don’t talk much about…
Well those sound like the perfect ingredients
for a VisualPolitik video!
We are talking about Guyana, an old British
colony who didn’t get independence until
1966.
Interestingly, at the moment of independence,
both the government and popular opinion was
generally in favour of turning Guyana into
a socialist country.
It was this mindset which gave the country
its pinto-esque official name: the COOPERATIVE
Republic of Guyana.
But, let’s focus on the country today.
Guyana is one of the poorest countries in
South America.
It has crime and violence rates that are some
of the highest in South America…
And that’s saying a lot.
In fact, if Guyana is know for anything, it
would be for its place in the international
supply of cocaine…
Oh, and also for having one of the highest
suicide rate in the world.
With all this information, you’d be forgiven
for being less than optimistic about the future
of this caribbean country.
But, they may get lucky in the near future.
A NEW OIL POWER
All the signs are point to Guyana becoming
an oil power.
For the time being, this small republic, with
a population of about 750,000 inhabitants
has already got the attention and dollars
of multinational companies such as Exxon or
Hess Co.
In fact, after several years exploring the
area, on the 13th January 2017, these two
powerful oil companies announced the discovery
of what they think could be one of the most
significant oil and gas reserves found for
decades.
Oil reserves have been found in deep waters,
in the sea mantle, under the coastal waters
of Guyana.
Early calculations estimate that the amount
of oil which can be exploited in the country
is no less than 4,000 million barrels and
many experts affirm this could be a much larger
quantity.
So, it seems that this country holds a huge
fortune just off its shores, but the question
really is - how much is this all really?
Considering the price of oil nowadays, we
are talking about roughly $200 billion.
So, leaving other natural resources aside,
only petrol, would result in the equivalent
of $250,000 per citizen.
And it’s important to note that the oil
reserves could be much bigger than the early
calculations indicate.
Now, it is true that oil exploitation is expensive
and requires enormous investment, but this
could still be the first step in a new era
of prosperity for Guyana.
So far the oil companies I have mentioned:
Exxon Mobil and Hess have committed to investing
$900 million a year in Guyana, over the next
few years.
The government is investing too, with plans
to start exporting oil in 2020.
This means Guyana could be on the cusp of
beginning one of the greatest economics developments
that South America has ever seen.
Yes, Guyana, that poor, violent country, could
become the kind of country which other people
in South America who are unemployed might
look at and think: “I want to change my
life, I want opportunities…”
Guyana could become that big hope for many
people in South America.
Nevertheless, before they start packing, we
have to say that it won’t be that easy.
The road ahead is fraught with difficulties...
CONFLICT WITH VENEZUELA
Much of the oil exploration is happening in
waters which are claimed by Venezuela.
And, the part they have claimed is not exactly
small...
Maduro´s country considers the region known
as Guyana Esequiba to be theirs.
And this region represents more than 70% of
Guyana´s surface!
So essentially Venezuela is claiming the entire
country as their own!
And if this wasn’t bad enough, another area
which makes up 7% of its territory is claimed
by their neighbours in Surinam.
If their neighbours had their way Guyana would
have been carned up and split between them
long ago.
The thing is, this conflict over territory
seemed to have been forgotten for years.
This was likely a consequence of the good
relations that the government kept with Cuba...
a country that holds a lot of influence over
this part of the world.
It was also likely because Venezuela wanted
the support of organizations such as CARICOM,
the Caribbean Community, of which Guyana is
a member.
So, you might be wondering, is Guyana a Caribean
country, or is it a South American country?
Well it’s sort of both... geographically
speaking the country is South American.
But, politically, socially, and culturally
speaking, Guyana is a Caribbean country.
In fact, Guyana was one of the countries which
used to benefit from PetroCaribe, an initiative
by Hugo Chavez that was supplying cheap, high
quality, oil to those countries which were
deemed "friends".
But it all changed when, in May 11th 2005,
the left-wing government of the People's Progressive
Party lost the general elections to a coalition
headed by the new president David Granger,
a man who was closer to Washington and who
decided to end, once and for all, the claims
coming from Venezuela.
At that moment, the long ignored conflict
defrosted and things started to heat up.
The conflict is today in hands of the United
Nations.
But, whatever the solution might be (if there
is any) it’s important to be aware of this
threat to the potentially prosperous future
of Guyana.
RACIAL CONFLICT
Another important risk is in the recurrent
racial conflict in Guyana, which is a continuous
presence in the country’s media.
Guyana is a complex country demographically:
around 50% of its population is of Indian
origin while 40% is of African origin.
These two big groups are not exactly on friendly
terms.
In fact, the black minority claims that, for
years, the Indian majority has obtained privileges
from the government and always got their way.
This has triggered recurrent waves of violence.
Luckily, the situation seems to have improved.
In fact, the winning coalition government
is quite multiracial.
However, there is still the possibility that
further internal conflict will flare up.
In any case, not only does this new government
have a great opportunity to overcome decades
of conflicts once and for all, but it was
also elected to fight violence and corruption
in the country - something that Guyana certainly
needs - being one the most corrupt countries
in the world according to Transparency International.
So the new government has quite a few major
tasks ahead of them... oil exportation as
well as a fight against corruption and criminality
in the country.
The thing is, if they achieve their goals,
Guyana will attract great attention and may
become the richest country in South America,
if they use their resources well.
But will that happen?
That is the big question...
So what do you think?
Will Guyana be able to successfully take advantage
of their newly discovered oil?
What position should Venezuela adopt?
Well, as always, I hope you found this video
interesting.
If that were to be the case, please do click
that like button and subscribe to the channel!
And if you are looking for something else
to watch be sure to check out our video on
why Switzerland is so wealthy.
You can watch that video by clicking here
(points).
And as always, I’ll see you in the next
video!